[Music]
all right thank you everyone so as you
heard my name is Mark EE SH and I'm here
all the way from Melbourne Australia so
I am awake for now but we'll see how we
go I'm here today to talk to you about
designing with react and this follows on
really well from Andres talk so Thank
You Andre for that setup there so
designing with reactors obviously a big
topic I'm just gonna scrape the surface
of it and my experience is with it and
hopefully you'll take a few pointers
from it now in Australia I work at a
company called seek you probably haven't
heard of them but in Australia it is a
household name it's the leading job site
there everybody knows about seek and a
big part of the work I do there is in
the space of design systems and the
tooling around that to support the usage
of design systems now what would a
design systems talk be without some sort
of quote about what they are design
systems are all about bridging the
divide between design and development
but for me really ultimately what I'm
excited about is being able to design in
the final medium as someone who's very
much interested in design and
development in fact when I started my
career in web development the line
between the two was somewhat blurry and
I didn't know which way I was going to
go and Design Systems is very much the
way that I can kind of capitalize on
that today so designing in the final
medium to me is what it's all about we
can do that in react because of the
component model it's very very powerful
andre talked at length about how much
components enable this way of thinking
because components let us build our own
domain-specific language we get to
decide what the markup for our for our
brand is for our design language we can
work with designers at our in our teams
at our companies to make sure that we're
properly capturing the design intent as
components we're seeing this at scale
across the industry you've got things
like Polaris from Shopify all these are
open source you can go check them out
you've got lightning from Salesforce
you've got carbon design system from IBM
and it's seek we have our own that we've
had for a number of years now I'm all
built on react seek style guide and this
is something that you know proved it's
worth very early on and it's become very
popular within the company ours also as
open source if you want to go check that
out but and there's a big but with this
is an issue
this is still
your design experience you open up
sketch and you've kinda got this blank
canvas and you can kind of draw whatever
you want and all of that hard work that
you put into your component system is
kind of nowhere to be found by default
you might have some earlier sketch
designs in this case that designs that
put together but conceptually in terms
of getting things to production those
are early drafts not the final versions
the final versions of our of our
components are not to be found here so
what we need is a way of feeding back
into design this is a problem that our
industry is facing a lot of smart people
are working in this space the most
notable of which that that really
influenced a lot of people's thinking
Andre mentioned it as well is react
Sketchup this came out of Airbnb and
John Gold's work there at the time it
looks something like this so on the left
there you've got react code and on the
right it's rendering into sketch now the
catch here is that the code on the Left
has to be written in a platform-agnostic
way effectively it's it's like writing
react native code you'll see it's made
out of view in text nodes at the bottom
there it's rendering a document and all
of these things allow you to render a
sketch file which is really really cool
so as I said these are for this to work
it's kind of coupled to the tech choices
that you make in your application
there's a more general purpose solution
that's less coupled to those choices
called HTML Sketchup I find this one's
actually a lot easier to use because you
don't you again you don't have to shape
your app code around it basically as
long as a browser can render it you can
snapshot it and export it to sketch so
we have a hidden route on our style
guide that looks like this it's all of
our components and all of them
notable States top to bottom each of
them is wrapped in a div with a data
attribute that allows us to select them
find them and convert them into sketch
symbols this is done via the use of an
open source command-line utility we
released called HTML sketch app CLI it
runs puppeteer behind the scenes for you
and and and does it all automatically
you just pointed at a URL tell it where
to write to on disk and JSON files come
out the other end which can then be
imported into sketch so you saw a bit of
a taste of this earlier and Andres talk
this is what a real experience for a
designer is at sake I using this system
you'll see there when you go to insert
instead of working in raw low-level
primitives of shapes you've got those
high levels
cymbals and each of those cymbals
importantly is following the design
language rules that have been set in
sikh style guides so all those
components and the various states are
named in the exact same way that
developers will find them in the code so
again as andre talked about we've got
that shared language between designers
and developers being reinforced at that
tooling level on a daily basis for
designers so what we're seeing here is
this move towards designing with
components and making sure that those
components are shared across this
boundary this is something that people
have done with clever tricks and mad
science with sketch plug-ins and so on
but we're starting to see that this is
moving into the realm of you know
polished production ready products that
are working this way from the ground up
the most notable in this space is of
course framer X so what you're seeing
here is is a UI where you're dragging
and dropping components into the frame
but what's important to note is that
those components on the Left are all
written in react you can go and look at
the source code for them you can play
around with them you can create new ones
you can publish them to a store so that
you can go and download entire sets of
UI components or publish your own if
you've got your own design system and it
means that now designers and developers
are not just sharing you know
screenshots effectively of your
components but the actual real
components and they're the props on the
right-hand side they are by far not the
only people operating in the space
you've got module studio as well a
building a product that looks like this
interplay is another really good one
what I like about interplay is that it's
web-based so it's much more fluid and
integrated I find integrates into github
and so on and what you're seeing here is
in actual usage of it with our design
system so we've been trialing this at
sea and it's been working really well
for us so again you've got those same
rules of the components that you've
defined in your system are available
there on the left-hand side and the
design the design flow is much more
tailored to your own specific design
language rather than these low-level
primitives what I love about these tools
again as someone who's interested in
both sides of this is that they're
blurring the lines between design and
code they're really making it so that
that when we collaborate on on our
products we're really sharing the same
underlying toolkits well what I want to
highlight today is
this question of what makes these design
tools what is a design tool that sounds
very philosophical but to me if I if I
go down the list the first thing to note
is that they're easy to set up and this
is in stark contrast to a lot of our
development tooling you know downloading
a copy of sketch is easy to get started
or if you're using a web-based
equivalent like figma for example
there's no setup at all you just go to a
website and it's ready to go once you've
got that tooling ready to up and running
new documents are cheap you can just
create new ones on the fly there's
really no friction at all to creating
new documents and within those documents
the iteration is really fast so if
you've ever watched a designer work in a
tool like sketch you'll see that it's
all about iteration it's about making an
artboard and duplicating it and
duplicating it and fanning out and
trying ten different things and seeing
what sticks and then refining refining
or refining until you you start to land
on something you like and that's where
the next steps really important is that
once you've got something that you like
it's really about sharing it with people
it's about making sure that other people
in your team other designers developers
product people and so on
everyone's getting some visibility into
the ideas that you think are working
well so if you're working with something
like sketch you can take that document
you can send it to someone via slack if
you're using a web-based version like
figma you can probably just use the
built-in sharing system send the link to
someone that's the beauty of the web of
course and it makes the whole process
really streamlined end to end but what's
interesting to me is that if you really
think about it these design tools are
still working under the same assumptions
they're still kind of built on this
foundation that to me is really where we
were ten years ago or more maybe not so
much where we are today and that
assumption is that code is slow when I
started my career in web development
this was true for web development it was
slow and it was arduous and you had to
know the low-level details of HTML and
CSS and JavaScript at length and you had
to juggle those three technologies
independently all the time a lot of
copying and pasting very slow if a
designer watch do you work they would
get very bored right is this true
anymore so if you look out at web based
development tools you'll see that we've
been
away this for a long time jsbin has been
around for a number of years now and
with zero setup just opening a browser
going to a URL you have a JavaScript
riffle there on the left you can just
type out code and it's running live in
the browser because your browser can run
JavaScript and there's a console on the
right we can console.log things so if
you're teaching people how to code you
know that the barrier to entry is so
much lower than when I got started you
don't have to install anything here
run kit is an interesting one in that
it's integrated with NPM website so any
NPM package you're looking at you can
just one click go and start playing
around with that package know you're
needing to set up a new project and
download the the specific version of the
package and then import it and make sure
that you're using it correctly you just
one click and here you are playing
around with lodash right in the browser
babel is another interesting one in that
you know they've got this challenge
where they had to convince people that
it's really not a big deal the
transformations that it's doing to your
code in and and they had to make people
understand what's going on with their
code now it can't cover this earlier
which is great you know this is kind of
how I learned
what's going on with JSX because the
babel ripple lets you just type out a
function that returns some JSX or even
just a raw J sex node and you can see
there on the right that is turning into
reate a react up create element call so
all that that scary magic that babble
supposedly was doing actually boils down
to something quite simple and this tool
was really instrumental and making me
understand that and again there was no
setup I didn't have to install Babel and
set up an environment and then inspect
the output they realize that they can do
this all in the browser because it's all
written in JavaScript typescript is
following the same approach here with a
try I guess what they're trying to
convince you here is first of all that
typescript is approachable but they're
also trying to convince you that the
transformations that it makes your code
are not that severe you can see that the
the typescript on the left and the
resulting code on the right you know
when you look at that that code on the
right is probably probably not too
dissimilar from the code you would have
written anyway and that's really the
point they're trying to drive home and
again I didn't have to install
typescript or set anything up it's all
ready to go right in the browser because
it's all just JavaScript code pen is a
much more visual version of this where
it's all about giving you those HTML CSS
and JavaScript
along with a set of configurable
pre-processors and then you can see the
output there at the at the bottom and
what's interesting here on the on the
code pen side of things is that they're
much more about the community and making
sure that when you build something
interesting you can share with share it
with other people and iterate on their
work and build new things to the extreme
end of this this really blew me away
when I saw it as I'm sure it did for
many of you is code sandbox so code
sandbox takes us to to the nth degree
where it's basically a full development
environment in the browser so it's got
the code editor in the middle like you
would expect and it's got the preview
pane on the right that's all pretty
standard from what we've seen so far but
on the left-hand side you can see we've
got a full file system basically we can
create new files on the fly we can
import them from each other and there's
a package.json you can go ahead and
start adding dependencies here and it
will install them for you when you're
finished you can share your work with
others there's a fork button so people
can go and take your ideas and build on
them you can create templates that you
can share so if you want to in this case
there's a react native for web starter
kit that you can just boot up and start
playing with a lot of people use this as
a way to get people playing with their
more complicated setups and boilerplates
and frameworks where it might involve
multiple files but again no setup
required you don't even have to have
something like the Visual Studio code
installed you don't have to have NPM or
node just open up a browser really
incredible stuff now if you think about
you know these points that I highlighted
about design schools it's actually the
same we're seeing the same things
applied here on the development side
where they're easy to set up it's it's
cheap to create new documents it's
really fast to iterate live in the
browser and when you're when you're
happy with what you're building you can
share your work really quickly and
fluidly with others because it's the web
just send them a URL so how does this
apply to design systems how can we apply
the same thinking to the world of design
systems and component libraries that we
work with every day we have a bit of an
ace up our sleeves in the react
community because of JSX the the ability
to declaratively lay out a set of
components and not have to think about
the implementation details of how we
actually build up a UI imperative lis
behind the scenes means that that bridge
between design and development can close
to news
while still talking in code and that's
really the key to what I'm excited about
because I had this problem where the
more I invested in our component system
I wanted to make it so that our
component code was more approachable
that potentially non developers could
even play around with JSX the language
is so close to the way they talk in in
daily usage as we heard from Andre that
it's really not that much of a stretch
to ask them to put it in a JSX like
syntax the hard part really is all the
surrounding stuff it's learning how to
set up a development environment how to
manage it once you create a document how
do I import react and export a component
and once I've exported it how do i
render it there's a lot of setup to do
the actual JSX bit is is really simple
that thinking long story short really
led me to the creation of this tool
playroom that we've been using at seek
for quite a while now and rather than
tell you about it i'm going to give you
a bit of a live demo so this is the 6
star guide website that you saw before
now it's very much your standard design
system website where you can see the
list of components here so I can look at
the alert I can see the alert in the
different states and get code snippets
and that sort of thing that's all very
standard but what's interesting here is
that we've got this play room link live
here in the browser so again without any
setup I've got this design environment
here it's very much trying to look like
sketch although it doesn't look so great
on this monitor the top section is more
of a gray not a white but here we go
so at the bottom there I can start
typing JSX
now again that that's the key thing is I
don't have to type react code or
JavaScript per se I'm really just
writing JSX so I'm going to add a header
component to the page and as easily as
that it's gone and rendered our standard
header across the top and it's
responsive so you can see we've got a
pane there at 320 pixels 740 1024 and
it's interactive so I can click to
expand this header I can set my
authentication status for example so
I've got autocomplete that's powered by
prop types or typescript if your files
are written in typescript as well so
let's set the authentication status to
authenticated and then I'm going to set
my username to mark and there we go so
now I'm logged in I've got my name sit
there at the top
when I expand this it's it's as though I
was signed into our website now what I'm
going to do is add a footer as well and
we've set that basic frame of a seat
page with very little ceremony no setup
and even some nice tricks around the
fact that I'm currently providing two
sibling nodes behind the scenes we wrap
it in a react fragment so I don't have
to think you know you think about a
designer if you taught them the basics
of react they'd probably trip over this
straightaway they'd say how come I can't
just render a header and footer and
you'd say how are you I haven't taught
you all the tricks yet we try and make
sure that this is as streamlined as
possible okay so we've got that frame of
a page let's add some text to the page
so we'll add a text component and we'll
say sign in that text is very small so
what we going to do is we're going to
change the size and again here's the
auto-completion for the size of our text
we're gonna say hero now at the moment
that text is hard up against the edges
of the screen that's because we need to
manage the whitespace so I'm going to
add a section component whoops
and let's wrap that around there and
it's all in one line so what I'm gonna
do is format it so I got the pseudo save
write command yes it formats it with
prettier in the browser if that's what
you want to do and so there we've got
our basic sign in our header at the top
let's flesh this out a bit more and do
our again our hello world of a sign-in
form we're gonna add a card to the page
and now I'm going to add a section again
to manage that white space I'm gonna add
a placeholder text field let's format
that okay so that text field needs to
have a label let's go ahead and do that
will say that the label is of course
email address and we will duplicate that
and we'll add another one which of
course would be password now this is a
real form obviously it's not just a
picture of a form so I can interact with
this as if I want now that password
field if we want to be nitpicky let's
let's say that that actually is of type
password and hide it so as easily as
that it's maintained the state and it's
rear-ended and that password is now
blanked out you can see that what's
interesting about designing responsively
although again you can't really tell on
the screen is that that form is going
all the way to the edges of the screen
and we might need to manage that
and at the moment our component system
really doesn't provide a good way for us
to manage that sizing so I might have to
add a hacky inline style and say that
the max width is let's say 540 you can't
really tell on the screen but the field
doesn't go all the way to the end now
and that's particularly noticeable as I
scroll across and look at the 1024 wide
version which that forms starts to look
a bit ridiculous at full width
okay so let's round out this form by
adding a button group and we're gonna
add two buttons first of all we're gonna
add a button that says submit it has no
styling by default we have to tell it
which color we want let's go with pink
that's our primary brand color we'll add
one more button which is a cancel button
but we'll make this of type transparent
cool so there we go there's our basic
sign-in form I could obviously go a lot
further and have it remember me and so
on but you can see that in the same way
that we saw earlier with these visual
design schools I had the same ability
here except it's projected across mobile
and desktop simultaneously and I'm being
forced to use our design language with
JSX in a way that really drives API
design from the beginning now the next
step of course from here would be to
start sharing my work with other people
as I said before now you can't see it
because I had it full screen the whole
time so let's drop out of there up here
in the URL it's a bit small but there's
a base64 encoded version of the code
that's in that pane at the bottom so if
I were to take that open a new tab and I
send that to someone on slack for
example and said what do you think about
this they can open this up in their
browser and there they go
they've got that form that I just
created but it's not just a static
picture of course if they want they can
start to play around with it and and
let's say that the designer said I don't
want that button to say submit I wanted
to say sign in they can change the code
if they won't start to play around and
send it back rather than having a modify
a picture all right cool now as I said
this was a this is a tool that we built
it's open source so it's not just for us
internally this is available on NPM if
you're MPM install playroom it's a CLI
tool and there's two main commands to
run which is start and build start runs
it up locally in as a development
environment and builders what generates
aesthetic assets that you can
to our website so what we just saw
before was hosted on github pages it's
as easy as running player and building
and doing that just like all good
JavaScript tools it has its own config
file and that's how this works so what
the way the way you configure it as you
pass it a file that contains all of your
components or exports all of your
components that's how we know what to
make available and that's scope so you
don't have to import anything as you saw
it also supports theming so if you have
a set of themes you pass it a file that
exports all of your available themes you
can configure the frame component that
wraps every single iframe that you saw
there so that's where you might set any
global contexts that require that's
required for your app particularly if
you're doing things like theming you
might have to do that you saw there that
we had responsive widths going across
the screen those widths are configurable
and so whatever widths you care about
when you work you can configure that
here that blank styling starting page
that we saw before can be a bit
intimidating and sometimes it's nice to
set up some example code when you start
so you can configure that as well
this whole tool under the covers is
built using webpack of course so that
web pack config if you need to is
available here to extend it so if you're
doing anything fancy with typescript for
example as we are in other in other
places you can configure it here now I
mentioned themes briefly I want to go
into a bit more detail about themes
because I think this is where play room
really shines over alternative tooling
and particularly with the work we're
doing and that's because at seek we're
actually building a new design system to
ultimately replace seek style guide
that's because seek is actually the seek
group of companies we have a number of
brands that we look after and so what
we're looking to do is have the ability
to build UI component Ori or build pages
that can be shared across all those
brands simultaneously at the moment we
have separate design systems that
haven't been built in the different
regions and we're trying to bridge that
gap with our tooling so what I'm gonna
do is show you what braid looks like
here's the braid website again very much
just standard design system website the
difference of course being that now
you've got different themes for every
single component but again we've got
this playroom link under tools so here's
a sign in form but rendered across the
different themes again live in the
browser you
see that the difference here between
them is a lot more notable so it's not
just a simple palette swap it's actually
changing all the fundamentals of the
design system which has been a really
good exercise for me actually I'm
because these are pre-existing brands
that we're having to to merge into the
one system so they've got different
typography which is notable but the
typography is built on top of an
underlying grid system and that grid is
different for every brand as well so
that means that things like the height
of text fields the heights of buttons
the space between things is all
configurable it's all different and so
you can imagine that when you start to
look at traditional design tools opening
up sketch for example and saying okay I
want to design for three brands today
how are you actually gonna do a
realistic design across all those brands
and get it right it's actually really
hard and doing it in code assuming
you've got a good underlying system is
actually easier than using a tool like
sketch and so this is where player in
really starts to shine for us but as
developers I think what's interesting is
that you've got that obvious appeal of
being able to expose your design system
in a really approachable way what I've
found interesting is how it's augmented
our workflow as developers as well so
the first thing to note for me is that
it's really impacted our development
workflow particularly on braid where the
need to support multiple brands
simultaneously is something you have to
think about on a daily basis so this is
not uncommon to see at the moment if
someone's working on braid typically
across multiple monitors but you would
have your your editor open in one window
and you'd have the browser open to play
room in another and what's happening
here is there's actually kind of two
things being juggled at the same time
you've got the developer iterating on
the underlying code of the system in
this case changing some styling of a
button but then you've also got a
real-world usage of the component in the
context of a form and you've got the
code that drives that underneath it so
what we're seeing is a real push to
think about not just is this component
good in isolation but how well does it
fit into an overall system and does it
make sense when I combine it with other
components we really want to make sure
that that design API is a first-class
part of the design the design and
development process and we want to make
it eration speed a real focus of our
tooling when we get closer to production
or production in the
of a design system and releasing our
changes it's been really interesting to
see how it's augmented our pull request
workflows so we're big on pull requests
and making sure that everything goes
through a review that every pull request
gets built and tested and and up to the
standards that we expect before we
merging merge it into master so here's a
pull request that we had recently for a
text field here's all the the the status
checks for the pr including a deployment
at the preview site so every single
build of every pore request gets its own
copy of the whole website including
playrooms so that means that I can go
and check out a snapshot of the work
from this pull request and try it out
for myself
from scratch just start to play around
with it so here it's a text field I'm
going to put that text field in a card
I'm going to add a prop to that text
field of a label or we'll just say hello
world and I can see what it looks like
across the different brands and I can
interact with it and get a feel for how
well does it animate how well does it
interact now if I jump back here what's
really nice is that the the the person
who's authored this PR has kindly
provided a playroom example for me to
try out again because the URLs are
shareable so here's an example not just
of a text field in isolation it's an
example of what a text field looks like
in the context of a real form where
there's maybe multiple elements and some
of them have different labels and and I
can start to have a play around with it
again in the context of a real
application at scale trying to build
more realistic designs how old is this
stack up to my expectations of a design
system so this has been invaluable for
us to get a feel for the new components
coming in and to even push the
boundaries of what they can do we've
discovered bugs by this process actually
being able to play around with that
component and what's funny is that as a
developer I'm very much set up to pull
down the code install the dependencies
build it run it locally and test it out
but in reality I'm Way too lazy to do
all of that right what I want to do is
just click a link and start playing
around with the new version right away
and so that that's become an invaluable
part of our process so it's exciting for
me to see that what we've stumbled
across is this idea of having a de San
box for our design language something
that requires zero install zero setup no
building or running things locally just
open and you open a link in a new tab
and off you go and doing so in a format
that's really inviting for non
developers does
owners have started started to play
around with this tooling and they find
it really helps them understand what's
going on in our heads as developers now
one thing I want to call out before
continuing I guess is that I don't think
this eliminates traditional design tools
what I think it does though is it
reframes their purpose we really have to
think carefully about in this new world
of design systems what it what are the
tools supposed to do for us in and what
stage is in our workflow UX people are
really big on this idea of wire framing
and have been for a long time and I
don't think they're onto something this
idea of saying that if what you're
trying to do is quickly iterate on high
level concepts of what you're showing to
a user what screens are going to be
provided and in what sort of workflows
this is the space to operate in when you
want to get down to the nitty gritty
detail of your design language this is
the space you should operate instead
which is to define that palette so that
when you flesh out those wireframes
you've got this high fidelity palette to
work with and you start to pick and
choose those elements as you see fit to
fill out those those high-level flows so
practically that means that low fidelity
iterations should be on paper if you
want to move fast do it do it on a piece
of paper with a pen and we can translate
that quickly into code and once we get
there that high fidelity iteration
should be in code again with the
assumption being that we have a system
that we're building up over time so that
we're empowering ourselves to iterate
fast in high fidelity with the real
thing in the final medium so we're
seeing the rise of code powered design
tools like framer X and so on but what
I'm really interested to see is is how
we as developers can tackle it from the
other side by having design power
development tools development tools that
teach us design as we work and make us
have workflows that are as streamlined
as and productive as designers and
making it so that every day when we go
to work we're thinking almost the way
designers think and trying to make sure
that our code actually supports us in
that endeavor so as I said our playroom
is open sourced so if this is operating
in a space that speaks to you please do
check it out plug your own components
into it plug your own themes into it try
it out try getting your designers to
play around with JSX I actually thinks
think it's possible so please do that
check it out let me know what you think
and together we can
make it even better that's it for me
today thank you so much for listening
you